Turquía critica a occidente luego de que
9 países entre ellos Estados Unidos
Alemania y Reino Unido advirtieran sobre
el riesgo de posibles atentados
terroristas en contra de sus misiones
diplomáticas y anunciaran el cierre
temporal de sus consulados y centros
culturales en Turquía
[Música]
no importa cómo se mire esta situación
las declaraciones y acciones de cierre
son intencionales hemos hecho las
advertencias necesarias y continúan con
tales métodos sin compartir información
ni documentos concretos con nosotros
también tomaremos medidas adicionales
les transmitimos este mensaje ayer
la quema del Corán en naciones europeas
por parte de grupos de ultraderecha
elevo los temores entre las delegaciones
de países occidentales en Turquía
las quemas tuvieron lugar frente a la
embajada turca en Suecia luego en
Dinamarca y los Países Bajos Como
protesta frente a la negativa de Turquía
a dar su Venia a la adhesión de Suecia y
Finlandia a la otan estos actos han
generado ira entre la mayoría de la
población musulmana de Turquía y su
gobierno que asegura que los cierres
consulares dañan el turismo de ese país
desafortunadamente esta decisión se tomó
el día en que anunciamos nuestras
ganancias y objetivos de turismo estos
países están librando una guerra
psicológica contra Turquía la
convocatoria de Embajadores en Turquía
no es la única medida en esta escalada
detenciones diplomáticas el pasado fin
de semana ankara emitió una alerta de
seguridad para sus ciudadanos que viajen
a Estados Unidos y Europa al advertir
que podrían enfrentarse a ataques isla